el núcleo de un átomo de hidrógeno es un
protón y tiene una propiedad llamada
spin podrías pensar en esto solo como
una ayuda visual podrías pensar en este
protón girando de esta manera un protón
con spin es como una esfera de carga que
rota y cada carga en movimiento crea un
campo magnético
por lo tanto podrías decir que un protón
es un pequeño imán como un imán de barra
o la aguja de una brújula aquí en la
derecha analicemos la aguja de una
brújula la cual tiene dos polos tenemos
el polo norte el cual pondré en rojo
aquí y el polo sur esa aguja también es
como un pequeño imán de barra así que
podríamos dibujar el campo magnético las
líneas de campo magnético van del polo
norte al sur podría incluir un campo
magnético aquí
va del norte al sur va del norte al sur
a través de una línea de campo magnético
también podemos pensar en el momento
dipolar magnético de la aguja de la
brújula y el momento dipolar magnético
también es conocido como el momento
magnético es un vector que apunta en la
dirección del campo magnético del dipolo
tenemos dos polos el polo norte y el
polo sur
y el momento magnético apuntará en esta
dirección bien utilizando la misma idea
podemos volver al protón y pensar en él
como una aguja de brújula si está
girando de esta manera tendrá un polo
norte y un polo sur
déjame continuar coloreando el polo
norte de aquí el rojo podemos dibujar
las líneas de campo magnético podemos
dibujar las líneas de campo magnético
yendo del polo norte al polo sur lo haré
de este lado de esta manera también y
por lo tanto podemos también dibujar el
momento magnético del protón el momento
magnético del protón apunta en la
dirección del campo magnético del dipolo
así es como debemos de pensar en un
protón como un pequeño imán con un
momento magnético volvamos a la idea de
la aguja de brújula porque sabemos que
la aguja de brújula si la pones dentro
del campo magnético de la tierra la
aguja de la brújula apuntará hacia el
norte eso es lo que tengo aquí abajo el
momento magnético la aguja de la brújula
apuntará al norte de esta manera y
sabemos que por lo supuesto se atraen
así que si éste
el polo norte de nuestro pequeño imán en
barra de nuestra aguja de brújula éste
debería ser el polo magnético sur estoy
segura que algunos de ustedes saben que
ese es el polo norte geográfico y en
efecto es el polo norte geográfico pero
si hablas de imanes es de hecho el polo
magnético sur porque polos opuestos se
atraen
y este de aquí es el polo sur este
debería de ser el polo magnético norte
de la tierra esto es justo lo que pasa
cuando pones una aguja de brújula en el
campo magnético de la tierra y entonces
si quieres hacer que la aguja de brújula
apunte en la dirección opuesta aquí
tengo la aguja del compás apuntando en
esta dirección
deberías de darle energía aquí está mi
dedo tuve que rotar tuve que rotar la
aguja de brújula tuve que agregar
energía para hacer que la aguja apuntará
en esta dirección y espero puedas ver
esta pequeña marca que dejé en la mesa
espero que puedas ver esto estoy de
hecho moviendo esta aguja con mi dedo
para darle energía esto hacer que la
aguja apunte en esta dirección
requiere más energía que este si la
suelto si solo quito mi dedo la aguja de
la brújula volverá a su posición
automáticamente y apuntará en
esta dirección otra vez así que este es
el estado de menor energía y este es el
estado de mayor energía porque tuve que
darle energía para hacer que la aguja de
la brújula apuntará hacia abajo y
entonces así es como pensaremos en
nuestro protón podríamos tener podríamos
tener un protón y si tenemos un campo
magnético externo déjame continuar
identificando eso este de aquí estoy
diciendo que es un campo magnético
externo el que estamos aplicando déjame
llamarlo v0 y si pones el protón en este
campo magnético externo hay una
interacción cuántica entre el momento
magnético del protón y este campo
magnético externo y el momento magnético
del protón o se alinea con el campo
magnético externo o se alinea en contra
del campo magnético externo déjame
continuar dibujando eso aquí estaría
nuestro momento magnético
alineándose con el campo magnético
externo y aquí estaría el momento
magnético alineándose en contra del
campo magnético externo y podemos pensar
en eso relacionándose con el espín de
nuestro protón si digo que gira en esta
dirección
este es el polo norte y este es el polo
sur
puedo colorear mi polo norte aquí en
rojo y el momento magnético el momento
magnético apuntará en esta dirección y
para el otro si el momento magnético
está ahora alineado en contra del campo
magnético el protón deberá de estar
girando en la dirección opuesta podemos
imaginar aunque esto no sea exactamente
lo que está pasando podemos imaginar al
protón girando de esta manera haciendo a
este el polo norte
a este el polo sur esa es la razón por
la cual esta analogía con la aguja de la
brújula ayuda tanto porque hay una
diferencia de energía entre estos dos
estados de espn así que cuando el
momento magnético está alineado con el
campo magnético éste es el estado de
espín alfa y cuando el momento magnético
está alineado en contra del campo
magnético aplicado será el estado de
espín beta
y hay diferencia de energía entre estos
dos estados de espn igual que como hay
una diferencia de energía entre estos
estados de la aguja de brújula esta
tiene mayor energía que está aquí es la
misma idea o podrías pensar en esto como
lo mismo para nuestro protón hay una
diferencia de energía este estado de
espn tiene más energía que este estado
de espn bien volvamos a la analogía de
la aguja de la brújula si pudiéramos de
alguna manera aumentar el campo
magnético de la tierra me tomaría más
energía hacer que la aguja de la brújula
apuntará hacia abajo tendría que agregar
más energía para poder cambiar la
dirección de la aguja de la brújula pasa
lo mismo con el protón si incrementas el
campo magnético aplicado ahora dibujaré
un campo magnético más grande
aquí hay un campo magnético más grande
un vecero mayor incremento de cero voy a
incrementar la diferencia de energía
entre los dos estados de espn puedo
dibujar una mayor diferencia de energía
entre los estados de espn alfa y beta
ahora esta diferencia en energía
dibujemos las y esta diferencia en
energía esta diferencia en energía es
mayor que esta diferencia en energía
porque hemos aplicado un campo magnético
más fuerte nuevamente la analogía de la
brújula nos ayuda a entender eso bien
ahora hemos aprendido que tenemos estos
dos diferentes estados de espn y resulta
que un protón puede absorber energía y
cambiar de un estado de espn más bajo
del estado de espn alfa a un estado de
spin beta veamos un diagrama que muestra
eso vamos aquí abajo si aplicamos
nuevamente si aplicamos un campo
magnético externo hay dos posibles
estados de espn para nuestro protón para
nuestro núcleo
el núcleo podría estar en un estado de
espín alfa o en un estado de espín beta
digamos que tenemos un protón o núcleo
en el estado de espín alfa hay cierta
diferencia de energía entre los estados
alfa y beta hay cierta diferencia en la
energía y el protón puede absorber
energía y cambiar al estado de espn más
alto si aplicamos la cantidad adecuada
de energía
este protón puede cambiarse del estado
de espín alfa al estado de espín beta
déjame solo dibujarlos aquí este es el
alfa y este es el beta y cuando eso pasa
se dice que el núcleo está en resonancia
con tu campo magnético aplicado y por
eso el término de resonancia magnética
nuclear y entonces esta diferencia de
energía esta diferencia de energía entre
tus dos estados de espn corresponde a
una frecuencia porque que es igual
h no
donde él es energía y no en la
frecuencia y esta frecuencia cae en la
región de ondas de radio del espectro
electromagnético entonces ahora sabemos
lo suficiente para pensar en cómo
funciona la rm en tengo que resaltar que
hablaré de de f
r m n la técnica de rm n con
transformada de fourier en este set de
vídeos en estos tutoriales en una trm n
tomas una muestra de tu compuesto y lo
pones en un campo magnético externo y el
núcleo puede estar tanto en el estado de
spin alfa o el estado de sting beta hay
un ligero exceso de núcleos en el estado
de spin alfa y entonces someter la
muestra con un pulso corto que contenga
un rango diferente de frecuencias y que
ese exceso de núcleos puedan absorber la
energía y moverse de un estado de spin
alfa a un estado de spin beta cuando los
núcleos caen del estado de spin beta al
estado de spin alfa igual que como pasa
cuando retiro mi dedo de la aguja de la
brújula la aguja de la brújula regresa
al estado de menor energía la máquina de
rn puede detectar la energía que se
perdió y no
una señal en un espectro rm en aquí
abajo te estoy mostrando un espectro rm
n muy simple y obtenemos una señal
obtenemos una señal así que déjame
continuar dibujando esa señal aquí la
señal se ve así como una cresta y esta
cresta ocurre a una cierta frecuencia
este valor de aquí representa una cierta
frecuencia aquí vemos a la intensidad
que es el número de absorciones qué tan
alto bueno vamos a hablar de eso más a
detalle después tu pico está aquí en tu
espectro rm y entonces es posible
obtener señales diferentes a diferentes
frecuencias déjame continuar dibujando
otra señal por aquí de esta manera y
entonces esta señal está a esta
frecuencia y esta señal está a esta
frecuencia
si tienes diferentes frecuencias tienes
distintas diferencias en la energía aquí
y esto es lo que nos ayuda a entender la
estructura de moléculas voy a
profundizar más en esto en el siguiente
vídeo cómo puedes tener diferentes
frecuencias que corresponden a distintas
diferencias de energía entre el estado
alfa y el estado beta